the Washington machine that gobbles up
our freedoms and invades every nook and
cranny of our lives must be stopped we
borrow a million dollars a minute this
vast accumulation of debt threatens not
just our economy but our security we can
wake up now and do the right thing with
spending money we don't have Congress
will never balance the budget unless you
force them to do so
Congress has an abysmal record with
balancing anything our only recourse is
to force Congress to balance the budget
with a constitutional amendment the
enemy is radical Islam you can't get
around it
and not only will I name the enemy I
will do whatever it takes to defend
America from these haters of mankind I
say that your phone records are yours I
say the phone records of law-abiding
citizens are none of their damn business
to rescue a great country now adrift
join me as together we seek a new vision
for America today I announce with God's
help with the help of Liberty lovers
everywhere that I am putting myself
forward as a candidate for president of
the United States